dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly zsolnai-fehér today
we are going to talk about a great
algorithm that takes the facial
expression of one human and transfers it
onto someone else first there is a
calibration step where the algorithm
tries to capture the geometry and the
reflectance properties of both faces the
expression transfer comes after this
which is fraught with difficulties it
has to be able to deal with changes in
the geometry the reflectance properties
of the face the illumination in the room
and finally changes in poles and
expressions all of this at the same time
and with a negligible time delay the
difficulty of the problem is further
magnified by the fact that we humans
know really well how a human face is
meant to move therefore even the
slightest inaccuracies are very easily
caught by our eyes add this to the fact
that one has to move details like
additional wrinkles to a foreign face
correctly and it's easy to see that this
is an incredibly challenging problem and
the resulting technique not only does
the expression transfer quite well but
is also robust for lighting changes
however it is not robust for occlusions
meaning that errors should be expected
when something gets in the way
problems also arise if the face is
turned away from the camera but the
algorithm recovers from these erroneous
states rapidly
what's even better if you use this
technique you can also cut back on your
plastic surgery and hair plantation
costs how cool is that
this new technique promises tons of new
possibilities beyond the obvious
impersonation and reenactment fun for
the motion picture industry the author's
proposed the following in the paper
imagine another setting in which you
could reenact a professionally captured
video of somebody in business attire
with a new real-time face capture of
yourself sitting in casual clothing or
near sofa
helliya thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time